here's the thing if you want to move up
to iPhone 7 that's fine that's fine the
question I've got for you though is do
you have the money and if you don't have
the money it is not a need it's a want
you have a phone that works don't be
such a wuss you have a phone that works
don't be stupid
now if you've got plenty of money I got
plenty of money because I've lived like
no one else and now I live and give like
no one else and I'll move up and phone
and it won't it's like on a biscuit it's
not a big deal right I don't care
anything about I'm not going to move up
to the 7 I just got the other one
working but you know some of you people
are freaking broke and and you you're so
you've joined the cult of Apple to the
point that you think you have to have
the iPhone 7 or your life is not
complete really you ought to look at
yourself in the mirror and realize how
stupid you are and how shallow that is
that you worship at the altar of the
Apple I mean that's ridiculous people
again I carry one I'm not mad at Apple
it's a great product that's not the
that's why I've got one in my pocket and
if you want to have an Android and have
a discussion about that that's awesome
you get you an Android I don't care all
I'm saying is you should have the
freaking money and it ought to be a
small percentage of your world before
you move up in smartphone unbelievable
and it has become a status symbol like
driving a car you know like you're
afraid your friends aren't going to
think I'm cool if I don't have a modern
up-to-date phone well honey one of the
keys to learning to build wealth is that
you don't care whether your friends
think you're cool or not that's a big
part of learning to get control of
money's being a grown-up and not
worrying about if your friends think
you're cool so again if you want to move
up in phone Android or to an app the new
Apple 7 any problem with that but if
you're a broke person
you know really this is time for you to
reevaluate look in the mirror and
realize that you might be looking at
stupid right there in the mirror don't
move up and phone when you are a broke
person use the one you got don't move up
in car when you're a broke person the
shirt that you have wear it you don't
need a new shirt you're a broke person
quit buying crap you do not need if
you're a broke person how hard is this
it's really not hard but we get in this
whole comparison thing and it changes
everything and it throws you for a loop
and that you know I'm really excited
about Rachel's book because that's one
of the things that addresses love your
life not theirs don't look over there
and go I are some I won't be somebody
else I want to have a different life now
love your life you have a good life
really I mean compare it you know really
you have a good life but don't compare
it to somebody else's highlight-reel
seven money habits for living the life
you want this book is coming out in
about two weeks and if you haven't
pre-ordered you need to pre-order
because you can get $70 worth of free
items thrown in by pre-ordering if you
get the book before October 3rd the day
it hits the streets if you go to Dave
Ramsey calm and get the book there
Rachel Cruise calm and get the book
there we're going to throw in the e-book
I've loved your life not theirs the
digital audio book of love your life
they're not theirs we're going to throw
in a video talk of Rachel doing the love
your life not theirs talk at the smart
conference and we're going to give you a
copy and ebook copy of our number one
New York Times bestselling book that
Rachel and I did together smart money
smart kids for teaching your kids how to
handle money so buy the book for $20 pre
purchase it anywhere then go to our
website with your proof of purchase and
we will honor all $70 worth of goodies
if you do it prior to October the 3rd
and of course you can just go to Dave
Ramsey comma Rachel Cruz comm and will
automatically have you fill out the form
so we can send you all this stuff and
all this free stuff with it's $70 for
the stuff it's a good deal new book is
called love your life not there's the
seven money habits for living the life
you want now
and that's what you should do this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or five hundred
thousand dollar Endicott
[Music]